ce sont des affiches désormais
placardées sur les devantures de
nombreuses enseignes comme partout en
france les restaurants cafés et autres
salles de sport ont leurs rideaux
baissés à saint quentin en yvelines
parmi les derniers commerces encore
autorisés à être ouverts les
boulangeries la queue pour acheter du
pain si fait entre angoisse et sérénité
à d'habitude on achète une baguette le
boulanger s'étonner enfin pas
complètement mais il les habitués à ce
qu'on prenne une baguette à chaque fois
effrayant on fait un peu plus de courses
même si on n'essaye pas de réaliser les
magasins parce qu'il en faut pour tout
le monde et en 83 en effet quand même vu
la guerre j'ai quand même vu pas mal de
choses donc je prends les choses comme
elles viennent
chez comme tout le monde j'ai fait
quelques quelques réserves de conserve
quand même ils font fait pas une maladie
ouvert aussi les hypermarchés à
proximité de la gare de saint quentin en
yvelines cette grande enseigne a été
prise d'assaut
conséquence les entrées étaient filtrées
en début d'après-midi une ruée vers les
courses qui avaient débuté dès ce
week-end après le déclenchement du stade
3 par le gouvernement dans ce
supermarché de guyancourt il était
difficile de trouver certaines denrées
quelques heures seulement après
l'ouverture du magasin
le rayon pattes on l'a remplie hier
matin et ont commencé à vouloir tout
mettre et des cons remplissait ça
partait donc on essaye de le mettre de
l'europe et une fois par jour parce que
sinon des complices évident donc ils ont
essayé de faire profiter le maximum de
clients de pâtes et de demander des
denrées alimentaires de base en fait
pour servir le plus grand nombre nourrir
les personnes mais aussi nourrir les
animaux les animaleries sont elles aussi
autorisé à l'ouverture à coignard les
propriétaires de chiens chats ou encore
lapins étaient nombreux ce matin à faire
quelques réserves dans la perspective de
nouvelles annonces gouvernementales on
l'atteint mange qu'une sorte de foi qui
refusent l'alimentation en grande
surface donc du coup je viens faire des
provisions pour lui puisque on sait pas
où on va on sait pas pour combien de
temps la petite commençait à manquer un
petit peu de nourriture donc comme nous
risquons effectivement un confinement
on s'est dit que ça pouvait être
intéressant de
resto qu'un tout petit peu farouches
stocker c'est beaucoup dire mise à part
les commerces alimentaires la totalité
des magasins étaient fermés dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines aujourd'hui donnant des
impressions de presque fin du monde
ce parking d'ordinaire bondés est à
peine rempli au tiers aujourd'hui et des
restrictions qui ne sont pas sans impact
sur la vie économique du territoire
dans ce bar d'habitude très fréquentée
du coeur de l'agglomération l'ensemble
des vingt salariés sont désormais au
chômage technique priorité le personnel
priorité les fournisseurs avec
peut-être peut-être une petite
restriction sur sur les charges
locatives le loyer les choses comme ça
on a besoin de trésorerie
un bon il se trouve que le bistrot du
théâtre existe depuis 25 ans on a un peu
de réserve mais ça fond comme neige au
soleil social culturel et économique
c'est toute la vie des saint quentinois
qui est impactée par la propagation du
coffee 19 une vie au ralenti qui
pourrait durer de nombreuses semaines